Now that we have our ASA data parsed we can use it to render to the screen.
Although you notice that our previous drawimage function doesn't allow us to
draw sub section of an image. Effectively it only took in x and y position.
Thankfully there's a version of drawimage that supports this ability but we
haven't really discussed it yet. There's an advanced version of the drawimage
API that takes in a few more parameters giving us more control on how we want to
get the pixels to the screen. In order to understand more about this we cruise
over to webplatform.org so we can take a look at the data. The new parameters
that we should be looking at are this. First off we handle the same image object
that we took with our previous drawImage API. And then we have the source x,
source y, source width, and source height parameters. These represent the xy
position of our chart in our atlas as well as the width and the height of that
chart in the atlas. The destination x, y, width, and height represent the
position and size that this small subsection of our atlas is going to be drawn
to in the output canvas. So, for example, we can set source x and source y to 2,
2. Width and height to 32, 32. And draw to a position on canvas of 128, 128 by
64 by 64, drawImage is smart enough to know that if the source, width, and
height don't match the destination, width and height. To probably scale the
image to match the desired output size. For our purposes in grids we really
don't do any scaling so for 99.9% of the time source, width, height and
destination, width, height are the same size.